[Music]
hey Luke here at the outdoor boys
YouTube channel and today the Nichols
family is going on a bit of an adventure
a road trip in fact we're packing up
everybody in the car and we're gonna
head down to Florida for the Christmas
holiday and I've got to get all of this
in there yeah 30 years of Tetris 17
years of marriage and six years with
kids
I've got mad dad skills boom well guys
we're traveling from Virginia all the
way to southern Florida I'm gonna do
something kind of fun I'm gonna put
together these little treasure boxes
full of catfish and carp stickers this
is my other YouTube channel and some
gears and swags throwing knives hip
flask fishing boats we got a little bit
of everything I'm gonna put together
these treasure chests I'm gonna hide
them in the various states and cities we
pass through on our way to Florida and
I'm gonna leave clues and GPS
coordinates at the end of this video for
you guys to be able to find them so let
me show you what we got going on for the
next 16 hours here got Tommy ready to go
easy the Snowman we got with Jacob here
yeah Jacobs ready to go Nathan
you packed up good good we took less
stuff on our month-long world tour that
we did on this trip to Florida you ready
to go all right let's do this
alright we're hiding treasure boxes now
well it's been an 18-hour drive but
we're finally here it's now 3:00 in the
morning I'm a little tired so I'm gonna
put this up go to bed and I'll give you
a little bit of a tour in the house oh
yeah we got a pool and we got a boat
slip and the dock back there
well canal access we're gonna do some
fishing videos right here off in the
back of the house we're gonna be doing
several fishing videos on this trip and
I'm gonna be posting the fishing videos
in their entirety of my other channel
the catfish and carp YouTube channel but
this videos gonna be kind of more of an
overview V log about the whole trip so
I'll show a little bit of footage from
fishing but you want to see the whole
thing yeah go to catfish and carp today
is gonna be a take it easy so today I
gotta go unpack the car we gotta get
some breakfast brush my teeth
yeah what are you doing Nathan
oh you're relaxing nice you decided to
go in the pool well we got to figure out
how to turn on the heater is that a
papaya tree right in the right in the
front yard that's pretty cool yeah look
at this it's landscaping with seashells
do a little fishing and find out what's
in the water over there let's see I
can't believe his kid it's cold that
water's 65 degrees that he's just
jumping right in he's been looking
forward to this for like weeks
well Tommy wrestles with hypothermia I
am gonna go try some fishing here I'm
excited to get my gear out you okay bud
catfish a little hard head catfish right
there the saltwater catfish is really
common down here in Florida and they
don't get a ton bigger than this but you
can't eat them and I actually did a
catch and cook video on how to eat these
things a couple years ago I'll put a
link in the description catch catfish
[Music]
all this to Lillis is that how we should
do it Nathan okay
that cool Nathan good job buddy
I'm doing remarkably well on three hours
of sleep but I am profoundly tired
finally got the kids to bed I am going
to eat a big slice of key lime pie and
then I am going to bed and I'll see you
guys in the morning
well good morning everybody and welcome
to another beautiful
it is absolutely gorgeous outside and I
have forgotten how much I love actually
getting sleep so we're going to go ahead
and just have a low-key day today is
Sunday so I'm going to go to church take
it easy spend time as the families and
just see what happens look we got baby
Donuts well guys we're heading off to
church enjoy yourselves a nice Sunday
afternoon but I want to point out
something funny I've noticed about our
rental property see what that is that's
a sprinkler head see what that is
those are seashells
yeah they installed sprinklers on a yard
made of seashells I don't know maybe
it's to keep the hermit crabs well
hydrated what do I know you ready to go
to church buddy yeah let's do it
well guys we're back from church and it
is a relaxing day when I get changed the
boys want to paint with their mom we're
gonna drive around a little bit and just
kind of take it easy but this week we've
got some really awesome stuff planned
going fishing for Goliath Grouper we're
also going to go hunt giant Burmese
pythons at night in the swamps of the
Everglades so a lot of cool things going
on there but today all about relaxing oh
look at that that looks nice man you're
drawing an alien Nathan are you gonna be
painting - oh look at you go this is my
idea of a vacation I'm sitting here in a
chair looking out over the water eating
key lime pie is that how you celebrate
Christmas right here there
well it's been a very lazy Sunday but we
are gonna go drive and you'll see
purpose lights you guys wanna go do that
alright let's go find some Christmas
lights go look at boy I think you can
see some white this house
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
a nerf gun
oh that sounds right that was the best
christmas-light house I've ever seen
yeah that was that guy was bringing his
a game let's get these boys a bed but I
know there's gonna be fishing and
beaches involved you'll put your toe in
there that's finally warm is it that's
guys welcome to the gun show people hope
you've got a ticket
[Music]
look at that that is a pretty fish it's
pretty hey Jacob
you ready you're drifting out to sea
this is not a bad way to spend Christmas
Eve at all jingle bells jingle bells
eager to play in a pool on Christmas Day
[Music]
Oh guys do I go get some pizza I'm
hungry
yo yo the beach nope nope do I didn't
cool
well Tommy and Nathan have been in the
pool for about four hours now and have
no sign of slowing down or wanting to
get out so I'm going to just keep
fishing and relaxing and let's see what
happens this is the best Christmas Eve
I've had in a long time these are some
bigger ones look what I discard it's a
Shimano bait Runner reel and a rod if
you guys think I should do a rod and
reel restoration video with this thing
leave a comment in the comment section
click that like button now if you guys
want me to I'll see if I can't restore
this whole rod and reel setup well guys
the fishing action is pretty good right
now but the boys want to go to the beach
and it's Christmas Eve so why shouldn't
we let's go to the family to the beach
and I'll pick this up when I get back
look at all those seashells
look at that one look at that one
this is a beautiful beautiful way to
spend Christmas Eve I like this
Jacob made another shell yeah it's in
his mouth well my dear sweet wife wanted
a picture of Jacob on the beach the
sunset you know something nice instead
we got sixteen pictures of him eating
seashells and being tackled by mom I'll
pick it up with your hands it's off if
you hold them flat on your hand he
Wiggles a little bit really slowly but
he Wiggles you see all these clams how
they have a little hole oh you have the
little hole in them that's from a
starfish a starfish climbs on top of
them and then he uses his little suction
cups to drill a hole inside the clam and
kill it once the clam is killed then the
clam opens up and he eats him look at
that I think that's the spine of a
catfish right there this is pretty
awesome we're sitting here on a beach
collecting shells with the family
watching the sunset just having a good
time this is a great way to spend
Christmas Eve
all right you guys ready for some dinner
let's do this we trash restaurants look
at this mess what are you doing over at
the table Jacob just eating pie like a
maniac look at the amount of beach sand
on this I've become a more generous
tipper since having children I just yeah
Merry Christmas everybody
[Music]
guys you ready for Christmas boys come
on in come on in
Jacob's first Christmas it's the wonky
donkey you guys don't have to read it to
Jacob okay okay let's put that down
[Music]
there's a bug in that baggage
[Music]
it's a sorry backpack what's in there a
snorkel mask it comes to the robotic bug
[Music]
all right boys Jacob please stop it oh
well this is a very Merry Christmas
we've got our bacon and eggs and orange
juice the kids are playing the pools
warm the fish are ready to be caught
it's a sunny day it's supposed to be
high in the eighties not too shabby
all right yo the boys are interested in
going to the beach and trying out their
new metal detectors they got for
Christmas so we're gonna wanna give that
a try this is that sound fun Jacob
that water is chilly well my wife just
pointed out my legs and said look we're
giving a white Christmas oh yeah alright
you guys turn it on and you've got to
wave it wave it back and forth and when
you wave over something metal you tell
me and I'll come over and help you find
something find it okay
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
I think this is the most work we've done
in like four days we're gonna need an
ice cream break alright guys we're
leaving sanibel island and I just saw
the most epic mullet I'd ever seen in my
life on a woman okay
this lady had like afro okay white white
lady fro and then she had about a four
inch wide bullet all the way down to her
waist it was amazing maybe three inches
four inches on top party all the way
down to her waist man it was insane feel
like I should write this my journal
alright guys we're back from the beach
and me and Nate are gonna try to knock
out some more catfish and maybe some
mangrove snappers here
you ready Nate fishing without pants on
that's that's how you live life folks
right there there you go find him
[Music]
[Music]
all right we've got a lot of nice little
catfish here Nathan did a good job
helping me reel them in but it's
Christmas Day so I'm gonna go in and
make hamburgers for the family and my
wife is out picking up her parents that
are joining us and we're gonna have a
nice little family get-together tonight
welcome welcome it's another beautiful
morning and we got some adventures
planned today after breakfast we're
gonna head down the marina I'm gonna be
up with a fishing guide and I'm gonna go
fishing for Goliath Grouper which is
something I wanted to do for a very very
long time the water tables you've been
really cold so that might make things a
little bit tricky but we're gonna go and
see what happens
[Music]
hey hey Jacob take a loser favorite Beck
has taken me over to the marina for this
Goliath Grouper trip but we're not
bringing the boys that was kind of sad
but these trips are hard to bring the
kids along because they can't really
participate they can't reel in a 200
pound fish you know and I'm going to be
doing a lot of lure fishing where
instead of putting the rods and rod
holders I'm going to be holding the rod
so I can't fuss with the boys it's not a
good trip for him for little guys plus
they have all their Christmas presents
and a swimming pool at home so they
don't exactly want to go and watch dad
fish anyway so Beck is dropping me off
and I'll be John here Hey alright guys I
am super pumped about this I've been
wanting to go for Goliath Grouper for a
long time there's been a bucket list
item for a number of years and I'm going
with John black here with crazy lures
charters we're just getting some fuel
getting ready to head out and we're
gonna see if we can't catch some awesome
fish today well guys you know me I like
to fish in crappy weather and today
we've got a good amount of win it's in
the like 20 mile per hour
look 20 to 25 knots Wow so we got
Whitecaps and all that good stuff it's
pretty nice weather on the outsides
about 70 degrees but the water
temperatures in the low 60s which makes
things dip
[Music]
low ladyfish all right we just got a
couple live lady fish we got them in the
live well nice big fat flight lady fish
we're gonna go see about some Goliath
Grouper we had this is definitely
something I come back down here and
definitely check out crazy lure fishing
guide service here with John I'll put a
link in the description contact
information down here in the Fort Meyers
Cape Coral area give it a go tell you
about these dolphins we saw it was way
cool Oh guys we're having a good time
back at the house here that little Jacob
here who's gonna turn one year old very
soon
a little man look at him and we're
making some burgers and hang with my
woman love you baby
hold them Jacob is a daddy's boy right
now
well guys it's the end of another
wonderful day we're gonna eat some
hamburgers here and get the kids to bed
and I'll see you in the morning
love you go thanks for watching we hope
you enjoyed this video if you want to
see more great videos from the outdoor
boys don't forget to click subscribe and
check out part 2 of our Florida
adventure also check out my other
channel the catfish and carp YouTube
channel where I'll be posting all my
fishing adventures in their entirety
thanks for watching guys and don't
forget to click Subscribe we put out new
videos every Saturday morning